[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat stress charge de
travail burn out
les raisons du malaise chez les forces
de l'ordre sont nombreuses depuis le
début de l'année vingt membres se sont
donnés la mort pourquoi une telle
explosion du nombre de suicides dans
cette branche professionnelle comment
éradiquer ce fléau mal-être chez les
forces de l'ordre
et c'est le thème du débat du jour
autour de cette table j'accueille julien
le camion soir bonsoir
vous êtes secrétaire départemental du
syndicat alliance police nationale dans
les yvelines à vos côté huguette foucher
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
régional modem titulaires notamment de
la commission sécurité
en face de vous françoise françois
bonsoir tout est psychologue du travail
vous êtes également la présidente de la
maison souffrance et travail qui est
basée à poissy quelques mots tout
d'abord sur cette association c'est une
association qui a ouvert ses portes en
2013 au 1er mars 2013 qui a 6 ans
aujourd'hui au départ j'étais seul
aujourd'hui on est huit psychologues à
travailler autour de la question de la
souffrance au travail
au démarrage il ya eu 800 consultation
aujourd'hui on est à un peu plus de 7000
passage donc c'est normal
merci en tous les cas tous les trois à
d'avoir répondu présentes ce soir alors
je le disais en introduction un triste
chiffre 20 membres faisant partie des
forces de l'ordre se sont donné la mort
depuis le 1er janvier 2019 parmi eux des
policiers et des yvelines julien le cam
comment expliquez vous cette vague de
suicides depuis le début de l'année
alors les raisons sont parfois multiples
et complexes malheureusement on dénombre
trois de nos collègues qui sont suicidés
en six mois c'est inédit sur le
département
moi je parlerais essentiellement des
conditions de travail sur le département
qui ceux qui se sont dégradées et
forcément ce soir j'ai une pensée pour
la famille de mes trois collègues et
ainsi que pour leurs collègues qui
actuellement souffrent et qui évidemment
sont
traverse une vague de souffrance
inexplicable évidemment lors de cette
émission plus en détail justement des
causes qui peuvent amener à commettre
l'irréparable
huguette foucher en tant qu'élu comment
vous jugez ces chiffres alarmants
tout d'abord déjà je tiens à marquer ma
solidarité et ma compassion est vraiment
toute mon émotion par rapport à tout ce
qui s'est passé tous les suicides qu'il
ya eu en trop dans les yvelines
notamment ce dernier suicide de du jeune
laurent qui est pas les familles de nos
enfants c'est toujours une catastrophe
d'envisager qu'il y ait un suicide quand
ce centre est démuni on se sent un peu
coupable au niveau de la région de
france et au sein des commissions
sécurité nous sommes très fiers
d'accompagner au mieux la police
nationale la gendarmerie qui fait un
travail extraordinaire et nous essayons
dans la mesure de notre compétence de
t'accompagner de quelle manière je serai
alors la police donc au niveau de la
région ile-de-france donc est très
présente mais faut donc des transports
des lycées et nous faisons tout pour que
les moyens mis à disposition la police
soit vraiment le plus adapté possible
concernant les transports on est mis en
place donc les portiques de sécurité
dans les lycées le bouclier sécurité qui
fait en sorte que ça va sécuriser quand
même l'entrée dans les lycées et puis et
puis aussi concernant donc là la police
municipale
on aide beaucoup au financement et à la
rénovation donc des commissariats du
matériel qu'il faut l'avouer aujourd'hui
est dans un état absolument dramatique
tout à l'heure avec monsieur nous
parlions entre autres du commissariat du
vésinet que je connais un peu
travaillent dans des conditions qui sont
des conditions aujourd'hui en 21è siècle
ils sont assez à signer miscibles un
françois francoual le risque de suicide
dans la police est deux à trois fois
plus important que dans d'autres corps
de métier pourquoi selon vous alors moi
je dirais déjà que rentrer dans la
police on ne rentrent pas dans la police
parce qu'on a vu de la lumière
souvent ce sont des métiers patients en
tout cas moi les policiers devaient
rencontrer que je rencontre encore
aujourd'hui sont des gens qui ont choisi
ce métier là leur objectif c'est d'aller
protéger la population
aujourd'hui moi ce que je vois c'est des
gens qui sont encore sous le coude
vigipirate il faut pas l'oublier
en plus des gilets jaunes cdc des
fonctionnaires qui sont sollicités quasi
en permanence condé des temps de travail
qui sont extensibles qui ne voyais pas
beaucoup leurs familles et qui n'ont pas
beaucoup de temps pour se refaire une
santé si je puis dire et
et puis qui se retrouvent dans des
espèces de solitude aussi et aussi je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup qui souffrent du
fait qu' ils sont la cible des civils
et ça ça c'est incompréhensible
en tout cas de mon point de vue je sais
pas s'il est important d'agir et on
parle du rythme de travail par exemple
mes collègues qui travaillent en police
secours sur la plupart des
agglomérations du département n'ont
quasiment qu'un week end sur 6 de repos
4 2 c'est sa quatrième après le 4-2
effectivement donc nous on tire la
sonnette d alarme
lors des chsct on parle de
désociabilisation malheureusement mes
collègues on est une profession
grandement touchée par les divorces sauf
que quand vous rencontrez un policier où
une policière qui d'un coup va avoir un
système de garde
bon bah forcément lorsque vous passez
devant un juge de présenter un week-end
sur 6 de repos bon forcément ça vous
déstabilise vous rentrez dans parfois
dans des périodes de souffrance
bon il faut savoir malheureusement aussi
qu'il ya une politique chez nous du
management qui est à revoir entièrement
le management n'est pas adapté on est
une profession effectivement très
particulière bon
adapter le management recréer si vous
voulez une une cohésion parmi les
troupes
il faut savoir que malheureusement de
ces dernières années tout est fait pour
que la cohésion disparaissent dans les
commissariats on est un métier très
particulier on à faire au quotidien à la
violence à la mort effectivement ces
moments là sont les moments importants
malheureusement tout est fait pour qu'il
n'y ait plus de cohésion ça oui donc les
saouler de manière insidieuse vous avez
la politique du chiffre dans on a
instauré des on a on a instauré des
outils informatiques dans la police
nationale qui permettent de tout
recenser et notamment la main courante
informatisée donc vous avez toute
l'activité d'un commissariat qui est
recensée et les chefs de service font la
guerre à tous les moments de sport les
moments de cohésion on voit des salles
de repos disparaître des commissariats
bon alors sous couvert de manque de
place évidemment les chefs de service se
trouve toujours des explications
sauf que c'est des endroits qui sont
importants c'est des moments où
justement vous resserrer les liens dans
votre équipe
parfois la plupart des policiers dans
les yvelines sont issus de la province
et trouve à travers leur leur brigade de
roulement la bac leur gsp une forme de
deuxième famille est en fait tout est
fait pour casser ce phénomène par une
politique du chiffre qui est encore
présente
justement vous en pensez quoi il va
toucher de cette politique du chiffre
eh bien écoutez justement ça tombe très
bien c'est que c'est politique du
chiffre et est remis en cause
justement par
la nouvelle mandature enfin par macro
puisque en début 2018 il ya une
commission au sénat qui était donc
diligenté et cette commission a fait un
excellent travail puisqu'elle était sur
le terrain et elle a fait ressortir
entre autres ce problème donc de
conditions travaillent ce problème donc
de deux stress ce problème de cassure
effectivement pour beaucoup de policiers
qui viennent de province qui sont
complètement coupés de leur
environnement voilà donc cette
commission a fait un excellent travail
et de cette commission est ressorti que
barras et politique du chiffre qui avait
été effectivement mis en exergue il ya
quelques années cela et dont on sait
aujourd'hui les dégâts monstrueux que
cela a fait donc cette politique du
chiffre aujourd'hui normalement n'existe
pas n'existe plus ce qu on essaie
aujourd'hui de remettre en place
effectivement des conditions de travail
plus adapté à l'humain parce qu'il ya
quand même un humain derrière et de
casser malgré les impératifs de sécurité
qu'il faut mettre en place
permettre aux policiers d'avoir une vie
de famille donc aujourd'hui la politique
chief officiellement n'existe plus même
si effectivement il faut quand même des
chiffres pour le manager comme dans
toute entreprise il faut quand même
qu'il y ait des résultats quelque part
mais ça n'est plus cette politique du
chiffre
castratrice quelque part qui est qui est
in en place il ya quelques années un
retour peut-être a donc des conditions
de vie de travail justement pour ces
jeunes policiers qui viennent de
province et qui sont mis dans le bain de
façon absolument catastrophique
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya un retour
au bon sens un retour à ce respect de
l'homme elle ce respect du policier qui
effectivement comme disait madame c'est
des choix de vie ce sont des gens qui
ont fait un choix de se donner aux
autres donc respectons le et il y aurait
effectivement une politique de
management positive
donc c'est un petit peu le sens de ce
qui a été mis en place et qui continuera
tu mis en place par donc
la nouvelle les politiques de l'équipe
macron avec donc plus de politique du
chiffre
avec de meilleurs moyens des meilleurs
moyens matériels avec une
dématérialisation ce qui en fait
aujourd'hui concernant notamment les
dépôts de platon peu dématérialisée des
nouveaux outils
voilà c'est parti des choses qui
effectivement sont mis en place pour
aider au respect de la de l'humain qui
est quel policier
vous parliez de vie de famille un
françoise françois est ce qu'on peut
dire qu'aujourd'hui le métier de
policier est incompatible avec la vie de
famille je sais pas si on doit saisir
quelque chose d'aussi dossier global ou
généralisée il y aussi des policiers qui
réussissent à combiner leur vie
personnelle avec la vie professionnelle
par contre moi ce que là où je
rebondirai quand même c'est à dire que
les policiers si beaucoup tombent c'est
c'est cette interaction entre un travail
énorme
un travail où il cherche à bien faire à
faire du mieux possible
et derrière c'est cette non
reconnaissance du travail qu'ils font
alors ça reprend tout ce que vous dites
voilà c'est la reconnaissance par la
récompense la prime mais pas seulement
en fait c'est tout simplement le matin
quand vous arrivez au commissariat c'est
peut-être d'être tout simplement saluer
bonjour par tout le monde
voilà qu'on ignore pas c'est c'est
d'accepter que ben voilà tel week end je
ne travaillerai pas parce que bah oui
j'ai mes enfants à garder parce que
c'est mon tour de garde s'est arrangé
mutuellement les uns les autres pour que
le travail se fasse bien je voudrais
juste rajouter que en fait le burn out
c'est la maladie des courageux il n'y a
que des courageux qui tombe à des gens
qui ont tout donné qui ont de l'éthique
des valeurs et un jour pas tout ça là ça
n'a plus de sens et les gens qui tombent
en fait parce qu'ils ont perdu le sens
véritable du travail
ils savent plus pourquoi ils travaillent
je viens le gain minime en cuc de
reconnaissance de la hiérarchie est
énorme c'est quelque chose qui ressort
tout de suite quand vous entretenez avec
les policiers voilà il ya forcément d'un
autre côté c'est ce qui arriva en défend
les les policiers qui pour leur
récompense est effectivement
l'administration on le voit a du mal à
récompenser les policiers bon par contre
de l'autre côté on est l'un des métiers
les plus sanctionnés il faut savoir que
malheureusement très vite vos actes de
bravoure sont oubliés lorsque vous
faites une erreur ça c'est quelque chose
qui fera beaucoup les collègues
je sais pas vous avez des policiers qui
vont aider une famille à sortir d'un
bâtiment en flammes voilà bon vous allez
avoir une tape dans le dos et puis deux
semaines plus tard on va vous
sanctionner parce que vous avez abîmé un
véhicule en allant sur une intervention
envoyée il ya des choses qui sont ces
quelque chose qui ressort très vite le
moins le manque de reconnaissance mais
moi je vous dis ce set cette politique
du chiffre
vraiment détruit la profession
et à créer un véritable malaise alors
moi je ça c'est quelque chose forcément
les bons et je parle au nom de tous les
policiers on attend une véritable
refonte du management il faut voir qui
est vraiment une cassure entre la haute
hiérarchie et la base ce qu'on appelle
la base et enfin mettre en place de
véritables actions de prévention parce
que notre ancien ministre monsieur
cazeneuve en 2015 annoncé un plan anti
suicide
on voit que qu'en est il justement
monsieur collomb a pris la relève en
disant je ferai de comme priorité vos
conditions de travail et améliorer vos
conditions de travail
on est en 2010 9 depuis le 1er janvier
on a vingt policiers qui se sont
suicidés en six mois on a trois
policiers qui sont suicidés dans les
yvelines
il n'y a rien de fait voilà concrètement
je moi de sur les yvelines
rien n'est fait pour il y a deux
médecins de prévention pour tous pour
plus de 2000 policiers
vous imaginez bien la tâche des médecins
c'est ce sont les médecins qui font
partie ce fameux service de soutien
psychologique le ssp haut c'est bien ça
oui alors oui alors il ya le ssp où il
ya la médecine de prévention mais et
puis il ya aussi un tabou c'est à dire
que quand un policier va mal oui il faut
franchir le pas il faut qu'il aille voir
le médecin
et là forcément parfois le pas est
difficile à franchir
on est dans un milieu où effectivement
bon le fait de d'aller consulter un
médecin
voilà est assez difficile et
et nous effectivement on dénonce tout ça
alors des chsct 1 le préfet le directeur
sont au courant on tire la sonnette
d'alarmé depuis des mois on a
l'impression de ne pas être écoutés que
mais paul que les mes collègues ne sont
pas écoutés et au contraire qu'on fait
encore voilà je me suis entretenu ni
encore avec un chef de service qui
faisait la chasse à au moment de
cohésion voilà c'est quelque chose que
nous on dénonce malheureusement les
plans envoyée il ya beaucoup d'annoncés
de fait par nos ministres
mais on n'y a rien de d'effectifs
françois de france avoue oui enfin je
pense que votants de cohésion vous
pouvez travailler ensemble à discuter le
enfin moi j'aime beaucoup la pause-café
en fait parce que dans la pause-café il
se dit plein de choses nous c'est le
sport c'est à travers le sommet jamais
collection retrouvent parce que oui vous
même lors des entraînements ce qui est
indispensable pour le policier c'est des
moments où vous retrouver entre vous et
vous pouvez échanger débriefer d'une
action qui a vu la veille
violente voilà vous pouvez parler entre
vous ça s'appelle des stratégies de
coping du coup c'est efficace
oui on voit ça aussi dans les services
de soins quand il ya eu un drame dont
voici un peu partout aujourd'hui sarah
flex qui est très positif en fait mais
la personne qui va mal celui qui
commence à rentrer dans ce processus de
syndrome anxio dépressif réactionnel je
préfère ça plutôt burn out
en fait les personnes qui commencent à
tomber on monte on de ce qui leur arrive
et ne comprennent pas souvent ce qui
leur arrive et la culpabilité c'est de
ne pas être comme les autres ou de
tomber
et là c'est le début de quelque chose
qui va mal finir
et donc du coup on va pas s'identifier
auprès du collègue en lui disant tu sais
moi je vais mal et c'est peut-être ça
qu'il faudrait prôné c'est-à-dire oser
le dire ne pas avoir honte de ce qu'il
vous arrive
voilà je dis nous parce que ça
m'arrivait aussi donc je sais de quoi je
parle et d'en parler librement et de
pouvoir en parler aussi librement en
médecine de préventive parce que il
m'arrive encore aujourd'hui d'entendre
dire que ça n'existe pas le syndrome
anxio dépressif réactionnel en lien avec
la pression du travail au moins une fois
par jour j'entends ça et ça c'est à moi
ça mérite un jeu montant de pouvoir le
dire son plateau bien sûr que six à
exister que si on n'y prête pas
attention oui il peut se passer quelque
chose de très grave
alors qu'un policier mettre fin à ses
jours mais qu'avant de mettre fin à ses
jours il ya aussi des policiers il faut
y penser à eux aussi ils mettent d'abord
fin aux jours de leurs proches
et après ceux de la mort donc c'est pas
juste le policier c'est le policier sa
famille parce que quand on tombe en burn
out ça rayonne
il ya plein de dégâts collatéraux
huguette touchée je reviens juste sur le
plan anti suicide dont parlait julien le
cam qui a été mis en place en 2015
comment ça suis justement qui a pas eu
de
c'est pas poursuivi c'est que ce plan
suicide doit d'être accompagné il peut
être accompagné de l'intérieur sévères
de la part effectivement de de la
structure choléra gierach chic au sein
de la police nationale des services de
sécurité donc à chacun d'eux de
s'inscrire dans ce dans ce plan suicide
mais il faut effectivement des gens qui
prennent le temps de discuter
et cette mise en place de deux lieux de
discussion de deux lieux de cohésion je
pense que ça se met en place mais c'est
vrai que on n'a pas cette culture là
même dans d'autres secteurs que la
police c'est difficile de parler de
serre souffrance au travail
je pense qu'on a tous plus ou moins vécu
des moments difficiles professionnels on
va se replier sur soi-même on a
effectivement honte d'en parler
donc il faut que dans notre milieu
crucial on apprenne accompagner tout ça
mais c'est effectivement quelque chose
qui va se faire au fil du temps je
voulais rebondir aussi sur le fait que
aujourd'hui il ya ce problème là
effectivement de problèmes de peut-être
de management d'accompagnement à la doua
la doit à la souffrance et peut-être
quelques des nouveaux arrivants des gens
qui vont sortir des écoles qui vont
venir peut-être aider un petit peu les
commissariats qui sont en panne de
personnel ça va peut être donner un peu
de sang neuf
il est prévu jusqu'à la fin de mandature
jusqu'à au moins 2020
presque dix mille embauches quand même
deux prévues au sein des services de
sécurité
en général on parle de manque de moyens
dans la police
sur le département il ya cinq ans est
simple l'ancien directeur départemental
a détruit la sécurité publique
on est passé de 10,9 commissariat neuf
agglomérations on a fermé des structures
on a supprimé des postes de manière
massive sur le département depuis
d'ailleurs cette personne a été promu un
des directeur central donc voyez chez
nous le fait de supprimer des postes
détruire des départements et vous jouez
sur la sécurité des citoyens pas non
plus des fonctionnaires mais des
citoyens
vous faites des économies sur la
sécurité cette personne est maintenant
le directeur central
donc voyez comme quoi chez nous les
promotions se font aussi au détriment de
la santé des fonctionnaires de police
mais aussi de la sécurité
donc nous on comprend pas et
effectivement on doute de la véritable
priorité du gouvernement
quand ils veulent mettre en place les
quartiers de reconquête républicaine
règles républicaines en quelques
semaines vous avez des effectifs
affectés depuis quatre ans il ya un plan
anti suicide
sur le département n'a rien vu vous êtes
on a eu six sorties d'école de nouvelles
affectations un peu plus d'un an sur le
département ce qui est une goutte d'eau
on aurait besoin de deux quasiment 300
policiers sur le département pour
renflouer les services sauf que à
travers ce manque d'effectif
vous avez des enquêteurs qui sont
submergés par les dossiers vous avez des
victimes qui attendent des réponses vous
avez mes collègues qui ont parfait qui
n'ont pas les moyens de faire leur
investigation correctement donc l avoue
il ya certains commissariats sur le
département c'est une véritable
cocotte-minute
on peut parler également ci-dessus
recherche de travail je pense notamment
au service de protection des
personnalités au sein de la police
nationale puisque du coup donc les pôles
noir on sait que notre président
emmanuel macron et souvent notamment
dans l'est dans les yvelines selon le
président du sénat gérard larcher
donc en fait ce sont des policiers qui
sont
ce sont des missions qui se sont
rajoutés vous imaginez que le week-end
entre la garde de la lanterne et la
garde du domicile du président du sénat
vous avez cinq équipages police secours
en moins sur le département pour garder
ces personnalités on ne dénonce pas la
mission c'est que nous ce qu'on dénonce
c'est que ça soit une mission qu'ils
soient dévolus à la police secours non
c'est à dire que vous avez cinq
équipages en moi pour intervenir pour
aider les gens nous ce qu'on réclame
c'est que ces missions soient effectués
par un véritable service spécifique avec
des effectifs par enfin vraiment dédié à
cette mission et que l'on vient pas
piocher les équipages dans les
différents commissariats
parce que forcément vous vous rendiez
enfin vous vous dégrader le service
public or cette émission touche bientôt
à sa fin
on va commencer à conclure finalement
quelles sont les solutions pour prévenir
ces suicides au sein des forces de
l'ordre et faire en sorte que et bien ce
9e ne fasse plus les gros titres jusqu'à
la fin de l'année
on commence avec vos françoise françois
la queue
c'est une question difficile parce que
du coup on peut rien garantir jusqu'à la
fin de l'année
bah oui évidemment par contre moi je
vraiment je prône l' écoute en tant que
psy l'écouté puis que lorsque
effectivement les policiers vont mal et
s'ils n'osent pas aller dans leurs
centres spécialisés qui puisse venir
dans des endroits où la parole sera
libre et surtout ne sera jamais révélé
avec la confidentialité est importante
aussi pour les policiers parce que
généralement ce qu'ils nous disent nous
c'est qu'ils ont peur que ça se sache
donc voilà qui est d'autres maisons
souffrance et travail à l'arrêt des
embauches et et bien écoutez c'est vrai
que c'est difficile il est ce que vous
demandez là moi ce que j'y vois en tant
que conseil régional donc c'est qu'on va
essayer de faire au mieux pour
accompagner donc notre police nationale
locale avec des moyens supplémentaires
une vraie reconnaissance et et sachez
qu'en fait on est très fiers de police
quelle qu'elle soit l'accompagnement en
moyens moyens humains l'accompagnement
en conditions de travail meilleures avec
de meilleurs commissariat avec peut-être
des outils numériques qui vont aider à
commander hd enfin des enclaves a pas
d'exemple avez aimé à désengorger donc
les secteurs de plates afin que les
policiers puissent reprendre vraiment le
goût de leur vrai métier donc de
sécurité et qu'ils aient moins de tâches
alex affaire c'est difficile mais je
pense qu'on fait de mieux pour les
accompagner au quotidien en les aidant
et surtout avec une immense
reconnaissance pour tout ce qu'il fait
oui s'unir le cam on continuera les
défendre lors des sièges chez c'était
d'aller à leur rencontre
effectivement nous à part une véritable
refonte du management
réformer la politique du chiffre et
injecter des effectifs et surtout
travaillé sur la médecine de prévention
beaucoup et que effectivement nos
ministres qui se succèdent applique
vraiment les plans qu'ils essayent de
mettre en place voilà merci en tout cas
tous les trois d'être venu apporter
votre éclairage sur ce fléau au sein des
forces de l'ordre
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à tous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat
[Musique]